hi welcome to this tutorial first of all
in the projector you have the URL for
the github of this tutorial you can go
there and download all the materials for
these conference you were told to
install if possible anaconda if you have
anaconda in your computer you you'll be
able to run almost everything because
they are they are like it's you know
[Music]
Jupiter notebooks if not I can you can
out load the materials onto your Google
Drive I prepared everything to run on
the Google collaboratory so it should be
easy to for you to run it into the cloud
and you can even run it with GPU
provided by Google for free so you can
just go that direction uploading
everything into collaboratory or if you
download my slides you will have direct
links for opening the materials in
Google collaboratory so a more direct
way to work will be that just click and
you will have your Jupiter notebook open
in Google's collaboratory and you can
just try and run everything that that
will be amazing right so this is a
tutorial in which I will try to
introduce people into the most common
techniques work on the computer vision
field how many of you consider
themselves like beginners in the
computer vision file okay me more or
less experienced people here advanced
okay so we are going from beginner to
intermediate level I try to to vote that
specific way okay Who am I
the percentage told you completely
he went over my CV and just I'm a
computer vision especially McNally's I
out of two books and my company image
analysis based on Argentina we make
machine learning software development
for many enterprises and our verticals
are ecommerce and FinTech so we are
hiring so after the after the talk if
you are interested in working in
products related with this on or other
we are open to hire new people into the
big company ok this is a summary of the
talk first we'll be going through an
introduction of the field and then we'll
go through the main activities we do
when we do computer vision class image
classification detection segmentation
those are three main activities we do
every day and they are getting real
attention right now you know we will be
working with models from 2017 so we'll
start with the basic but the the journey
will take us until just the past year
okay just a little timeline of the field
of neural models just start in the 40s
we started with the perceptions I don't
know everyone here knows what the
perception or a neural net worries
please raise your hand okay I will take
from rent that more or less you read
about what a neural net worries and
the past history of it in the 60s where
after the perceptions were shown not
able to take title good important
Portland problems there were a first
winter in the field and then 1770s and
Ivy's we had the multi-layer perceptrons
who which did a very good job but in the
end of 90s 2000 we had like a second
winter in the field because the amount
of data and the computer power wasn't
really good to tackle advanced problems
then in the 2010 the the past years as
you saw all the new deep architectures
and every the field like got a new life
and that's the main that are the main
architectures we'll see in the news
course but we'll start just from the
beginning with a little introduction and
we'll do computer vision problem-solving
like they do in they did like did in the
80s so here is an example visual example
of the problems we solve every day for
classification we just take a picture
and we suppose there's just one subject
in the image it's well focused and it's
like a perfect case of computer vision
which is not the case almost and it's
not the case almost always but it's a
start then what we go on to
classification allocation in which we
detect the the real place the the object
is taking place and with object
detection the third one we just are were
just able to detect the multiple objects
in the bounding boxes up there and the
last one is the instance segment
in which we just can for each pixel of
the picture we which has the can
determine to which object it belongs
this will be our final objective in this
talk well I promised to use the toast of
Kara's and Joseph oh so I want to go
deeper into the libraries itself because
it will take all the place of the
computer vision materials but I will
just go a little bit into the crust
library which is the main one we'll use
to build the model from the ground up
crust is a high level
neural lattice API which is specialized
in building deep networks allows easy
and fast for arriving and for us the
most important thing is that it supports
convolutional neural networks recurrent
- we went we using them right now but
that's important and relatively in CPU
and GPU so you can switch architectures
which are problem just a little bit of
the elements we need to run a model with
chaos we need for building a model three
things an optimizer which will try of
course of training the works of the
network - to get the best possible
results an odd function which will guide
the optimization problem and a list of
metrics which which will measure how
well our our model is compiling the base
method for training a network will be
the fit function which applies to many
types of models we'll see just in a
minute the layered types that we will be
using for the computer
Provinces convolutional pulley and
recovery current is just for the sake of
complexity but we went we using eight I
know okay
when just the last theoretical aspects
of it for computer vision there are too
many the two main types of layers that
we used normally for building for us
building blocks for our networks the
convolutional layers and the pooling
layers then you have the old one there's
layer in which every element of the
network is connected with a diner
another in the case of convolutional
networks what we do is to Train filters
to extract features from the image so
our communal layers instead of having
like a row of elements will have like
little matrices which we have weights in
every one of these filters we take a
feature from the the image in which
translate to the other layer for example
a border some texture and when we pile
those together we we can get higher
level features for example we can
extract eyes the texture of a frog it's
like a complete set of filters that we
tried and the pulling layers mainly what
they do is to scale down the images
extracting a stock in just one type of
feature for example in this case we take
a 404 matrix and extract the maximum
element that allows to support many
scales when recognizing things if you
just go and apply this filter to the
whole
image you'll you'll just get little
elements so you you have to scale the
representation to be able to cover a
bigger area then continuing will care us
we have many different losses which has
the function we will be used to measure
how good our model is predictable things
and then we have the optimizers this is
a really good really important choice
you had to do when up to when training a
model as you see in this graphic
produced by Alec Radford we we are
comparing many different techniques in
order to get the minimum of the error
and as you see depending on what option
you choose for example STD is ranking
descent is the canonical way of training
a network but you see the results are
nothing compared with more modern
alternatives in terms of conversion time
so this is a very important thing to
choose then you have activation
functions it supports soft max value and
on the normal sigmoid you know Harris
supports the standard base of elements
to train models in support by Karis ok
let's start with the first example well
we start with the calcification problem
these in this chart I try to represent
well what will we do it during the
training of the pacification model we
will feeding the model with many samples
of beam images different types of images
our model will
in some way process all the information
and we'll through we show us a vector
representing the probability of the
image of being of a determined class for
example in this in this one let's
suppose this this class is the airplant
class so it rolls like 0.3 when we train
we this is supervised so that supervised
learning so we are sure that this is
airplane airplane so what will we do is
subtracting getting the error from the
training from a trained sample into our
level and then we will calculate the
error M back propagate this error in
order to the next time to get a result
closer to 1.0 and then at the inference
time we just do the forward pass
hopefully if the model is worth trying
when we feed an airplane to the model we
will get a really high result in the
airplane class that's the idea okay for
this first example we will start with
the amnesty data set of you that read
something about the deep learning can
attest that the amnesty dataset is the
most important one it's just a set of
thousand of hundred digits and it's like
the hello world of the classification
problems well to two years so one year
ago the company solando which sells
closest of the internet produced similar
data set with the same sect format but
it uses Clovis it has instead of ten
numbers it has ten types of clauses so
we'll try to train a model using this
newer newer data set will feed it into a
model we'll train it and we'll see how
they the increasingly complex models get
along with this new dataset we can say
that this new problem is much more
difficult at classifying
digits because you have to recognize
more complex elements in the in the
clothing items so okay for those of you
with a conclusion in there if you click
in the link there you'll open a
collaboratory instance with the example
in there or if you are downloaded and
have anaconda you can just execute the
number the example number one okay I
have it around here so well I will go
just about the code I don't need you to
understand everything I think you you
can keep the cold in investigate a
little bit because in this segment of
time with we're not allowed just playing
everything so in this first block will
be importing all importantly libraries
the chaos library then chaos has dataset
module in which you can just download
and use a number of very well-known
models in this case fashion amnesty is
one of them so you can download it and
and use it right away then we import
this equation model which is very
important
most of the networks that will be
building are a series of pile layers we
have different characteristics so with
the sequential module you can start and
get piling and piling layers in a
seamless way so it's really convenient
for simple models you just need that and
then here we'll import so the different
layer types we have for example the
dance is by well-known is the common one
drop out which is plain later community
land should dimension layer and max
pooling and then a flatten which is
plain later those are the different
types we'll be using then from the
optimizers we will get rmsprop in SED
they are very well known optimization
strategies matplotlib blocked our result
and okay the first step is to download
the m list dataset as you know it's
really prepared just to use it
so we download it in the next code is
just for show in a bit how the dataset
lock looks like so here we are just
graphing the couple of samples here you
have bad trousers here is a metric of
them you imagine that there is like you
know tell some of them will be using
them to train our model and well
here we define a train model function we
just calls the defeat function of the
model and then we able evaluate the
results of the Train the first case I
want to show you is a single layer with
ten units let me just show it it's not
okay I think I have a representation of
it okay
this layer we have the input one hidden
layer of ten elements and then we have a
final result telling us the final class
to which it belongs for the matrix I use
the accuracy measure and the optimizer
is the standard reading set pressing
control must plus enter you can execute
it so let's see how it how it goes yeah
sorry yeah it's a gradient descent is
the the standard method using in the
textbooks in which you have the the this
error surface you measure there and you
child try to go down into the error
surface until you you you get the
minimal error
yeah yeah yeah it's really a nice
historic way of optimizing but Adam is
really far superior because because it
adds momentum many new techniques in
order to and not to over fit or get
stuck into the you know the local
minimums Adam tries harder to not to get
stuck into the minimums of the let me
show you
I just you see a CD is more prone to get
stuck into local minimums
the mechanisms that Adam and other
optimizers used yeah yeah yeah yeah like
in the textbook yeah yes okay sorry
sorry I okay sorry I didn't include the
libraries
so here the Google cloud is downloading
all the needed information the data set
so everything is automatic from the Kara
site
then here we do some daily
accommodations here and we'll try this
one I won't try because I rocked like
you know like six seven models okay
I'm missing just this operation
just to show you one training with
historical artifact okay so as you see
chaos - it takes everything needed to
turn the model it's like a bit like a
magic but in order to to start with you
with tinkering doing with things I think
I find it it's okay I - see we start
with very low accuracy this model gets
more or less like 70% accuracy which is
not good well in the following samples
we what we are doing is getting more
complex architectures and seeing how
they perform I won't execute them right
now because it takes a little time but
but in this case for example we in
augmented the number of elements of the
single layer and we can get and up to
the 90s 92 percent of accuracy then I
just add a new layer with activation
value and here I introduce the rmsprop
ass optimizer then we get up to more or
less the same a little bit more 93 more
or less what I had later is the Ezra
Pound layer
drop out is a way of of training let's
say so what does the MACD sorry
drop out the the drop out layer what is
it takes a sample of the weights of the
network and every time we train or every
batch it like the cells a number of them
and the end result of this is like we
discussed with you here is it tries not
to over fit the model and I like to do
the the image of suppose you are you
have a ball in a surface surface and you
want to get it into the chest right down
when you have many protons here what you
have to do in order to get down is just
to to shake it well the effect of the
this report mechanism is like in shake
this the arrow surface in some way
that's just like a figure for that for
you and help us to get to the minimum of
the error and it's not liked by every
research in the world but in some cases
inwards so so they then we added the
drop out just be settling the 20% of the
weight every run and we get up to you
you know we are not getting too much of
a gain and then what we do here is to
introduce the first convolutional
architecture but for this example the
previous examples we we took the image
took every row and produce a long vector
which we fed into
network in this case for the this type
of networks evolution linear networks we
have to do to enter a madman trishal a
matrix or the normal image format which
is two-dimensional so we have to like
reframe the information in these lines
then we normalize into a float which is
also needed and build the model
it's a sequential model but it it has
two combinational layers then a max
pooling so we reduce the scale and get
the max element from the area drop out
flatten flatten it's the way we have to
go from choose the elements into one one
just one element in the form of a vector
right there you know you are working
your way into 2d version and then you go
into flattening the it's more or less
this way but in this case these are the
last neurons but they are linear like we
want to know to have with the flatten so
this this operation is normally done in
the in the latest layers of the network
after that we combine the model and fail
it so I'll just start running it in
order for you to see it but as you know
it will take some time okay so we fed
60,000 elements which is the size of the
M list and fashion amidst data set and
that the division between training and
validation is done automatically by
caress as you see we are starting at 87%
so it's much more power powerful that
the other models so this is a starting
point for our more advanced models so I
just interrupt execution just a tip for
running the collaboratory if you go to
run time change the run time type you
can choose to use a GPU you saw how fast
it it's going the training is because I
am learning hip you for from Google I
don't know if this will be a journal
that Google allows us to use the ship
use for free but you can make use of it
right now ok yes
well the kernel size at the moment it's
not like there's no silver bullet one
tendency is that the decals are getting
everyday smaller in general like they
started like 11 by 11 then 5 by 5
savings even that's even then 3 by 3 and
there we have a special mechanism which
is one by one i wanna i want explain
with that mechanism but they are getting
smaller but it depends on the type of
features you want to extract from the
from the the image you know i'm not sure
because they are getting smaller but for
the the examples we will be seeing BTC
network which has 11 by 11 convolution
elements
he is used and works really well but i
don't know in the future so there many
things in the
real are not like totally scientific
people are tinkering about and getting
results without a donation so I hope we
can't just in the future get more you
know that's a monistic we with the
measure which a but it's really like an
engineering effort right now that's why
all I can answer right now questions
another question okay well this sounds
really good but it's not that easy to
grasp in in theory so what I did was to
prepare this distance Cueva you can
download it or search ET in the github
page what
Quo Vadis that's is to use Karass to
load models and to show us what's going
on inside the accommodation under neural
networks so this is a BCC Network which
I will explain first because we want to
be able to understand anything ok let's
start with deep learning as it is the
last network we tried was kinda a deep
neural network like for the nerman
technician but it was a bit simpler by
today's standards so let me show you
more modern approach to the each of
these well in 2012 one important step
was
was leaving in order to advance the
field of computer vision what is the
image that data set it it has like 12
medial images classified by type in with
a classification tree inside it it was
really challenging at that time in order
to read to to train and as I said a
training model against the data set for
that reason new architectures were
developed for example here we have DBT
she architecture it was developed in
Oxford the visual geometry group and as
you see we have communal layers followed
by pooling layers and then like some
normal dense layers and the result is a
1000 vector element vector which says
the probability of the element to belong
into a class following that tradition
every year a challenge was done
searching for better model so then
Google entered the scene and produce the
Google net in which you have new modules
called inception modules which are you
know structure in the way I am showing
you and it produced really good results
improving the results of the BGC
architecture but you can infer how
complexes is that and then Microsoft in
2015
introduced their resinate which is the
last I think the last big big advance in
the field in which every layer passes a
bit of information to the following
layer in this kind of networks every
every time we do the pooling
whose resolution and will we lose
information this is not totally the case
with the residual networks so that's
again what we are visual
we will be visualizing right now is the
BCC architecture the quaver tool will
load that model these circles you see
here they are every of the every layer
you saw in the slide is just one circle
right there so let's see what what the
network sees from every sample I'll
start with a dock for example okay
what's shown here here what we have is
what the network is believing is the
class of the original image for example
here are the four five more important
features we we got from the image they
in the sorry for example golden
retriever has 26 percent of being of
that class in the in this in this
example we'll try to chest with with
another dog this data set has a very
good understanding of types of dogs and
cats so you'll get very good results in
that we are but but as you know we have
just one image one single object in the
certain center of the image and that's
easy for our nets to to infer but with
another example I'll show you later
you'll see when this doesn't work okay
so this is
the first combinational a layer of the
VCC 16 architecture as you see the
network train to get mainly the the the
border the edges of the images and some
kind of textures
you know this cell how it reacts to the
to the adult texture and probably it
won't work with a frog for example and
this is really characteristic of the
first stages of the networks but
advancing a little more and after the
first polling we begin to use to have a
less resolution but more general
features are highlighted like like this
the tongue of the dog so we we are
created like very specialized filters
detecting LM elements highlighting
elements differently from one sample
from the other and advancing a little
more you see we just seeing really rough
features right here until we get into
abstract elements probably looking at
one just one element from this filter we
won't be able to really grasp what the
network is highlighting but as use as
you know the final result is a sum of
many of the features so probably in this
case the
the figure of the dog will produce the
sum of many of the features producing a
high output for the golden retriever
class and not another so as you know
this is a bit difficult to understand
because this was trained like two weeks
in batches of millions of images so in
some ways it's like
it's getting like a superhuman
capability of observing so many times an
item an item an instructive information
but let's look what what happens when we
feed a figure with many many dogs you
know the predictions are like garbage
and near budget shop letter-opener corn
this is really strange
well what happened the network was
expecting like one element well located
in the center perfect so this is not the
case and you see the network at which we
spent many dollars training in one week
in a cluster it's throwing garbage yeah
because this architecture is not enough
for us to to tackle this type of
problems that will be the second part of
the conference okay let's go a little
bit okay how do we do we train a
particular deep learning model for
classifying well in this case we use
what's called the transfer learning for
what we do in this case in this example
what we'll be doing is taking a pre
train bcc 16 architecture trying with
you know the imagenet data set of
millions of miniatures this richness
which is grasped by the network we can
use to to apply it to our province in
it's really important when every mother
will train for now on we'll use a pre
train model which have very good
understanding of general concepts all
the concepts the the network was
grasping will take it but will train the
last layers of the network we'll just
cut it and train some weights at the
final so we'll be using the the previous
information they share information and
we'll introduce our our information into
the last fields or layers of the network
this is a really fast way of of training
and it was really well it's like common
practice okay
in order to reach all the objectives of
the tutorial I'll just show you this one
let's say faster because we have another
two tasks to do but don't worry I'll get
everything sorted out I hope the network
doesn't follow me I'll try to open it in
github - I was taught don't trust in the
way how to wireless but okay just a
minute okay I will open the our github
implementation so I'll show you that the
code I will use to train transfer
learning the first stage is
more or less the same but we introduced
a new concept like image data generator
and the application module which has the
VCC 16 model on it ok we start by
defining some contest for example the
image for the BG she's 16 the image size
effects you have to feed it with these
measures 224 by 2 tiles 224 images and
it can change and then we have another
concerns like the number of trained
samples we have we want to introduce and
bad-sized the number of images we will
train at the same time then we resort to
the application module of cara's which
has many of these right now
architectures inside and we will try to
instantiate the VCC network like like we
saw in the slide here we are asking for
it to contain the image net pre-trained
weights so we'll making use of the
weight somebody trained during weeks for
solving the image net challenge and then
in cloud top force so the top layers of
the network we won't be having in the in
the model we will we'll add our our
layers later
so after associated in the moment we add
some layers like the advanced layer
dropout in a final dance layer and in
which will we try to predict our results
the last one is a dance layer of two
elements because for this bear
the example I train a true kind of
flower classification so so it's easier
for you for you to grasp so we will be
going from it tells you classes to two
classes of images well what we are doing
here is upload downloading our dataset
which I prepared and as you see we have
this is a training set we have a
training set and validation one in the
training set we have two folders in the
folder number one we put the one of the
classes all these samples and then in
the number two the other one and this
code that I prepared will sort
everything out it will infer okay
there's this directory this do yes other
one and you will automatically infer
there are two classes and so on and here
is the validation set we are unzipping
it into the folder then we compile a
final model with the laws of categorical
cross-entropy
which is normally used to to measure the
error of classification in these kind of
problems and this is very important the
image data generate generator is a
functionality of cara's which allows you
to to fill the model which different
modifications made to the image it's no
input it's so good for a model to
understand okay this is a really adult
looking from the front and everything is
okay so you have to in order to
generalize you have to provide the model
with different views of other of
the sample so you just fill it with a
distorted shifted flip version of the
the images just in order to get a more
general model and that's what this
training set generated us for example we
just here we put the zoom range the
rotation range we just were just giving
the the parameters to the modifications
down to the images yes sorry
yeah normally when you will scale the
image we do have there are many
algorithms avoiding the loss of
information for example by linear
algorithms and there are more advanced
than that the the naive way is to just
take in one sample and pouring in the
array scale but this is the realm of the
OPC B library has many advanced
algorithms in which you can grasp a very
good representation of leg or foot of
pixels by linear is like the normal way
of filtering but there are even more
advanced filters in that we are but
because we are going to just get one
class from the be whole images that data
reduction is not that important because
the model has to be resist resistant to
rescaling clippings shifting so I think
the model is already prepared for not so
good inputs but in this case for this
example I just used the the normal
OpenCV rescale operations which I think
they use by linear filter and they work
well but that's a really good question
okay then here we will infer the the
data set from the directories we gave to
the to the model and it's a time for
training okay I will I won't show you
right now because I haven't time to
Train but basically what you will be
doing is feeding the model with a new
URL
for example this one and see if it's
okay okay you'll feed the model with the
URL it will run the model here is the
resized operation we are calling just
the standard opposite Evo operation we
will risk a the image pass it from the
model and what will be getting is just a
two element vectors showing the
probability for our model we are to
decide which class the this sample
belongs to so in this case this is
really strange you know pieces are
really a joy model by a train
it gave me it gave me like 100%
probability of the image to be in a
Coldfoot which is really not the
expected one probably the the model did
a bit of our feet the the getting is
right but the certainty is not it smells
like okay this is not so good well this
is everything from the classification
problem point of view yeah I'd really
like to advance but time is is running
so I want to show you more elements okay
let's go to the detection okay for the
detection problem what I decided to go
for is the tensorflow
object detection API first an
introduction to the data set that allows
us to get to this
point first of all the Pascal visual
object classes it was a dataset created
in 2005 which have the classes of many
many elements and additionally it has it
has annotations of every location where
every object is located so it was a
really good advance in the field because
it was challenging to solve to find the
elements and it was a new class of
problem that aroused from that this is a
XML file representing one images the the
most important thing is there is an
object here and this this is around the
box of the object okay after the the
classification probe a problem was like
solved you know you had 90% people
started working on detection and getting
the exact location of elements there are
too many approaches one is first Iran
algorithm trying to get proposals or
sounds where object will be located and
then running that whole model we have in
that's in those sounds and then we have
near newer models called Yolo SSP which
you only look once it's the name of it
you just go and in one look you try to
get the most of the image you don't have
a previous stage trying to get ok here
you must be have or an uncle you know so
they started we
the worker trying to solve that the
first version of the network we
proposals we'll be seeing is the arsenal
this network is like the continuation of
our efforts trying to locate elements so
the architecture is more or less the
same as we had but we have a
pre-processing and post-processing in
the pre-processing stage we first look
for region of interest inside the image
then we work the images and put them
into the 224 by 224 Soleil that then
they for every proposal we'll run it
into the recommendation and network like
we saw before and then for any of them
the SPM algorithm was run as we have
available is like it was really popular
in the 90s beginning of it mm it's used
now but not so much so then the last
decision about the class for every
proposal is done with SVM in work but as
you as you can see you you have to run
for example two thousand times every
proposal for through the network in it
was like really really slow so just one
year before the first our CNN
architecture appeared in which we replay
the the final decision about the class
of the proposal what was done with a
combinational network so we are using
each time a new newer neural network for
doing
tasks which world Danny really not
mother form I we are replacing like SVM
and other techniques by combinational
networks and that's a good thing because
we are just using the weight we train
for many operations instead of defi
dividing the work in three four stages
and then just like the past year not
2015 the faster our CNN architect to
appear in which all the work we were
describing in the first architecture is
done by CNN's from proposing regions to
doing the the final classification so we
have just one one big a convolutional
neural network based architecture for
doing everything and that's in this area
more or less state of the art we have
new alternatives but as these
alternatives keeps the way we are doing
starting from the the first introduction
I like to use it right now in this
compared in comparison you see that just
using convolutional neural networks for
everything
we are getting a huge speed up and the
precision is maintained from the first
alternative so you can just go more or
less real time with this alternative yes
yeah
in the first mechanisms it was like is
it's a you know not deep learning
algorithm which is in charge of it it
used like sophisticated I already know
but not using any convolutional layer
inside it
the new proposal architecture uses the
the information residing into the weight
or the convolutional network to take
possible blobs of information and
separates them from the background but
it just done with the information we
train with image in it that's a good
thing so if image NATO's so many
circular figures related to flower
well that will probably will trigger a
proposal around that so so that's the
advantage we are like knowledge-based
proposal instead of instead of algorithm
based proposal and I don't think I can
go much further because they are really
I'll just go to the paper in this case
okay here we have another example code
example we have here it is for a object
detection yeah
I hope the op it opens fast if not I can
just resort
okay yeah I think it will
okay any questions I hope there are many
but okay here and so in this example we
will be using a pre-trained network to
recognize elements into an image okay
I'll just use the pre-render notebook in
order not to take too much too much time
but everything you see was run just one
before we met okay
the first step we need is to use the
protobuf proto bad for libraries because
everything is in the object detection up
in API libraries if is used in proto
buffer formats then we proceed to clone
the chance of flow repository for the
model the research models and we have to
compile the definition of the more must
use architectures which is done in the
proto buffer the format we proceed to
compile them so we are ready to use all
the the premade modes well then we
include just a number of libraries which
is which are really standard in the
toolkit of computer vision and this is
very important we had you had to have
the mountains research in research of
the option detection all the those
directories has have to be into your
path your Python path because we are
using pre-made models which are included
in the option detection library I hope
these library advances
because we usually you should just can't
a peeping sole option detection API it's
really moving for that reason you know
when we in the following slide when you
train our model I have to pin the github
repository because it's changing every
day and breaking things apart from my
point of view it's like quite unstable
unstable okay so what we do here is to
download a pretty model which is the our
Sienna faster our CNN and the network it
uses internally if the resonate the last
one we saw you can you can just use many
different types of deep learning the dip
d-dip learn motors inside in this case
we use the ResNet okay just find a
couple of paths we download the model
into our path the model is represented
in a format in a sense of flow format it
has a way of storing the the network
graph and the ways in which s1 file so
we'll just load it in at once and it
will be ready to infer then we have the
load a label map which is adjacent file
containing chest and map for example if
class is number one this is a hat it's
not a hat but suppose it so just a map
from the results of our model choo-choo
text based label so this big method is
taking is taking from from the front
examples of the API it just takes a
dictionary of results from our model for
example the detection boxes
the detection masks and puts it in a
more chuk chuk chuk Tamil way it's just
data mangling here what we are doing for
example the number of detection the
number of boxes and so on then just a
helper function to do the analysis of
the results okay and this is the final
visualization of our results so in this
in this example we load the image
ran it we run the inference for the
single images into our pre trained model
and yeah and we get a dictionary with
the boxes and the classes in the scores
for every class for example this has
this region has the 80% of being cut for
example and then we run it into a sample
image do you'll be able to choose from
in your notebook from a number of images
or you can just insert the the URL there
and you will be just able to show you
fir in your sample images in this case
we of course it has to contain the cat
and dog classes and with high confidence
we are getting my name 99% in of the
right class so this is an example of
running using the object detection API
for the detection of in this case the
elements pertaining to the cocoa the
data set let me introduce it
okay four because if the detection we
did recently the model we you used use
the cocoa dataset to Train which has
ninety type of classes and it was
developed by Microsoft but now is open
and this dataset in format allows us
additionally to get the bounding boxes
of the elements is much much richer if
you do research in the future probably
you'll be representing things in the
cocoa format because it allows you to
annotate the images with with many
properties for example you can describe
any and a seed with text you can do many
new things that were not provided with
the the Pascal format so take this in
account
probably you we have you looking at the
cocoa format and data set in the futures
if you get into research okay
well what we can do and was one of the
promise of this course is to change our
own detector so what do we need in order
to create a new data set in this case
because the last one the last conference
I went with was in Italy I prepared a
pizza detector was already too I was
thinking about doing something for
London but didn't happen time so what we
basically did with the provided provided
code is to collect the directory
containing images divided into an image
and training images and validation one
for the
for create to create this dataset we
need to annotate the images and so they
it's all I choose which works very well
is the label image which is represented
here you can install it from pip and
basically you load a directory and begin
to select the instances of the pizzas
and I choose to mark the the pizzas
without not complete because you have to
sometimes to try to share allies the
concepts so you'll your village will
bear I you can just choose to represent
whole pizzas or you can accept not so
good examples for example this one you
can mark or not depending on the
objectives of your work
well finally I prepared a script because
it's not good friends with the
collaboratory the object detection API
right now or from mobile so I prepared a
script in which you install all the
dependencies you need you get the
Chancellor flow repository you pin it
into the February 5th
I had to pin it there because it's
growing like crazy and can break things
well then you install the object
detection API you download a data set
that I prepare it's an s3 then ok then
you unzip it and let's see how the
process go in order to prepare the the
final way or the final elements of the
of the model I started with the image
directory and every training and the
validation folders have the result of
these two it is one XML file per image
so what you have to do is to convert all
these formats into CSV in the at the
moment you can just use it directly you
convert it into CSV which is a comma
separated value file which it has for
example image in n boundary boxes and
then you generate ATF record file which
is a format accepted by the chancel flow
models in which you represent data
complete datasets just in one record
which is understood with four by
tensorflow
it's a binary string is really strange
format but I prepare all the code in
order to prepare the data it's on the
material so don't worry you can review
how the process go and finally we use a
train that PA utility provided by the
the API in order to train a final motor
in the final step just
[Music]
okay I think I have it here okay so just
a moment it should open okay the last
script gets the snapshot of the weights
of the network and the network
definition provides an inference graph
this or flow has a format to
impro to buffer format in which stores a
network architecture and its weight so
with the last script you you save that
and it's ready for consumption
I took the task to prepare a notebook
here the 4c notebook what they never
will do is to load download the Train
model and do inference to several images
you provide so in the material in the
materials you have the whole pipeline to
build your own detector it went a bit
long form I won't be able to show you
everything but basically we download our
own frozen difference graph and do the
same as the previous notebook load a
bundle get the image processing feed and
get a final image is just the same
process I just try to run it while I
talk
I now see if I will be able to to get
the results but here you have to result
I got
I provided with the menu from
Italian restaurant you can see here it
it's detecting 90% 99% and then here at
least it can differentiate from a Pepsi
or something like that so I use chest 16
elements for training a 3 or 4 for
validation and as you know it's working
too good
3 honestly I'm surprised so following
the structure of the the data sets the
model is downloading you can just
produce your own detectors increase the
quality for example one is rich not too
much maybe increase the quantity of
glasses you know ok that's all for the
detection I have like two minutes to go
to the last task which is image
segmentation well we were happy and we
were detecting our elements everything
went well but what happens for example
if you want to detect and there is like
an object which is very long or very
with extremities extend you know my
bounding box including the brief at it's
really really large in maybe for some
problems it doesn't size you anything
because you are just having our very
large bounding box in what's behind the
person or besides me or here so the next
step is to just get a mask of any
elements with the exact pixel where it
is located so this is the problem of
segmentation and following this
tradition it was already like obvious
what about if you had chest two
convolutional layers which of which
with the output of a mask for any of the
detective classes so the mask arsenal is
like the old architecture we use just
now and it has at two more layers trying
to get in the psych location of every
feature and for this very model we need
new formats because the Pascal didn't
accept it so the the MS Coco format
appear and the here format is like there
you you have you have the images and the
annotations and a couple of major like
metadata added here and the annotation
field is like this you have an image ad
catcher ad segmentation in which you
represent the borders of the element
using just like a bitmap compress a
compressed bit not is just like the BMP
port format from the old windows or a
polygon you just go and get the figure
segmented that way you can add just a
bounding box and many other annotation
types which are appearing for example I
kept a caption many many elements you
can add to it okay just a representation
of the the encoding of the of the mask
but basically you have the IDI type of
the element and the number of times yep
it's a purse a a times B six times but
this is the way we have to compress the
mask representation okay and I have a
seven minutes so I think it would be
okay so
here we have the object sanitation
sample and you see if it los well just a
moment not I will get it from the idiot
okay so for this segmentation model
we'll be using another library based on
cara's so this this library is was based
on cara's and it's made by the matter
port a company I found it better that
the object detection API because we the
object detection API just added the vast
arsenal like one month two months ago
and it's not really developed but the
matter port people did a very good job
implementing the this architecture and
it's made on Keros so we are not getting
out of our fields okay first we'll try
to segment using the cocoa dataset
basically we get the the matter poor
repository some tools we need some some
Python libraries needed for example for
determination then we just download a
pre trained model into our directory we
get a configurations from a custom
object the configuration for the for the
network are put in in an in an object
which is contained in the material so
when you review the cocoa
that pay Titan fine you'll see all the
configurations needed and you will you
will be able to trick the configuration
of the whole network so there's a good
number of things to play with
after the these tutorial so there we
load them here it's not as sorry but
here we are putting the elements of the
the classification task into a list we
week we'll just put a CSV file or
something like that but it's just for
the sake of clarity well and then we get
from a sample directory an image and we
apply the algorithm into it so as you
see here we get the segmentation done
and the class applied to it okay really
fast in order to can generate your own
data set you'll be will be able to the
BIA annotation tool it just added a
directory you open it and it's a just an
HTML you'll love the images and you
apply the apply the polygons into the
elements you want in this case I don't
know why I did a tire segment so I guess
I got like 50 40 images of cars
different locations and highlighted the
the tires
well after that of obviously we have to
Train it we have a format for it we have
a validation data set a training data
set with the che so for each one the
Chasen is provided by the tool we are
using
okay and then I provide you with the
code to do the the training of of that
and you you'll have also a short script
in which you can just execute that into
a vanilla bottle but - and it should be
all right I think I tried me so a lot of
time what we have to do we have a
dedicated notebook to do the define and
inference you just you just have to to
load that the model we trained I
uploaded into s3 the final results for
the Train model and okay in this part of
the code you have to provide your own
your own image it will just infer from
just past the your image through the
model and get the resultant mask and the
de library the multiple library provides
you visualization tools like display
display instances in which you'll be
able to apply the algorithm directly so
that is the results from the last
notebooks this is one of the of the
possible results you know here here here
well with good precision we can detect a
child and we start to chat for from like
this time 16:20 samples and for the
training and five organization and you
know as you can see it can infer
they have the final forms of attire
really well so just closing the tutorial
I hope you like it
I I think there are lots of elements to
review in your house but you have all
the elements in the materials I hope you
you found the this tutorial entertain
you bring house at least something that
should just want to try just the
interest in the field I hope you to see
you next time thank you
[Applause]